david bonjour vous êtes donc en direct
de cette manifestation n'est pas via
notre talent et l'anglo saxonne a bien
écouté le cortège n'est pas encore parti
de la place de la république les sapeurs
il s'apprête à partir le cortège va
s'élancer dans quelques instants la
mobilisation est importante mobilisation
intersyndicale et interprofessionnelle
pour répondre évidemment à la comté où
la décision du gouvernement de prendre
l'option 49,3 je me trouve actuellement
avec benoît tessin secrétaire général de
la fsu bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions benoît est ce que vous
attendiez à ce passage du 49-3 du
gouvernement alors depuis quelques temps
s'attendait parce que effectivement le
gouvernement est en difficulté au
parlement il ne répond pas aux questions
des parlementaires pas plus qu'ils ne
répondaient d'ailleurs nos questions
après pour tout vous dire c'est sûr
qu'on s'attendait pas à ce timing là
c'est à dire que quand même profité
d'une réunion du conseil des ministres
sur le coronavirus pour faire finalement
le 49 3 en plein week-end c'est vrai que
ça rend les choses encore plus
encore plus finalement condamnable selon
nous il ya un vrai déni de démocratie de
toute façon l'utilisation du 49 3 en
plus pour couper court au débat c'est à
dire c'est même pas comme le 49-3 avait
pu être utilisé à d'autres époques pour
se ressouder sa majorité est finalement
calmé sa propre majorité
c'est carrément parce qu'il n'a plus les
réponses face aux amendements qui sont
posées il est incapable de répondre aux
questions simples qui lui sont posées et
qu'on lui pose nous depuis le début et
qui lui étaient posées par les députés à
savoir quel est le niveau des pensions
quel va être le niveau des retraites et
c'est quand même pas une petite question
et c'est pas une petite question qui
concerne des situations individuelles
c'est une question de société
est ce que demain on va garantir aux
gens des retraites suffisante pour vivre
où est ce qu'on va au contraire aller
vers un système où les retraites vont
baisser massivement et ou du coup les
gens auront vaguement de quoi survivre
et c'est la question qu'on pose depuis
le début il est incapable de dire quel
va être le niveau des retraites
alors malgré ce passage du 49-3 est ce
que le débat est terminé est-ce que la
mobilisation va s'amoindrir bas en tout
cas est ce qu'il y avoir moins de deux
présences dans les rues selon vous non
selon nous en tout cas il faut continuer
ce mouvement est selon nous le 49-3 ne
siffle pas la fin de la récréation
le 49 3 c'est une forme supplémentaire
de manifestations du mépris quelque part
mais ça n'est certainement pas la fin
des choses
cette réforme elle doit rentrer en
application en 2022 et pour la plupart
de ses effets c'est 2025
et donc ce qu'une loi a fait une autre
peut le défaire parce que 2025 c'est
loin et donc nous on va continuer aussi
si cette loi était maintenue et si elle
passait au sénat et finalement si elle
était adoptée
on va continuer à peser sur l'opinion
sur les politiques dès maintenant parce
qu'il ya des élections municipales quand
même et donc on interpelle aussi les
candidats qui soutiennent la majorité on
est ensuite dans le débat politique en
général là tout de suite les choses ne
sont pas faites parce que la loi n'est
pas adoptée donc ce à quoi on appelle
nous c'est à amplifier encore la
mobilisation bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui il
ya moins de monde que lors d'autres
journées d'action parce que construire
une réaction spontanée c'est pas évident
et donc évidemment d'un jour sur l'autre
c'est normal qu'ils aient un peu moins
de monde mais par contre ce qu'on dit
nous c'est qu' il faudrait arriver à
reconstruire une très grosse journée
comme il y avait eu le 5 décembre et
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis le 31 mars non
pas pour dire on attend le 31 mars pour
réagir aujourd'hui on est dans la rue il
y aura d'autres actions
il y aura plein de choses le 8 mars il
ya aussi la manifestation des femmes
mais par contre l'objectif c'est de
reconstruire quelque chose de très gros
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on va gagner
effectivement si beaucoup benoît est
d'avoir répondu à nos questions là vous
l'aurez compris la contestation
populaire ne va pas s'arrêter à le
cortège elle va partir d'ici et quelques
minutes pour se rendre jusqu'à la place
de la concorde pour une fois de plus
réclamé le retrait de la réforme des
retraites
david merci pour toutes ces précisions